it is time for drew's news where the
suit du jour as always good news chowder
and with me at the desk world's best
co-pilot ross matthews oh hi everybody
uh this story intrigued me to no end
iconic bombshell pamela anderson is
ready to tell her own story on her own
terms variety reports that a documentary
all about her personal and professional
life is coming to none other than
netflix
yep that's the place to do it pamela
said on social media that she's not a
victim but a survivor and alive to tell
the real story and both her sons
reposted this note highlighting the
words real story so obviously they're
behind their mom
i'm now curious with this real story
what the
maybe the family feels the film pam and
tommy the one on hulu right now yeah yes
i
love it and i do think and i would have
to say i would not love it if it was
taking her down i'm just glad to see the
show is not doing her a disservice but
actually really opening up my eyes to
the
sexist incredible victim ways
that she was set up for
well it's interesting you know i like
the the pam and tommy series as well i
like it a lot but if they were making a
series about your life well for sorry if
it was my life it'd be way more boring
than their life but you know no matter
how they tell your story you still want
to get it out your way your version
today in the headlines uh she is a
culinary icon
julia childs
julia oh yes and food and wine reports
that the food network is launching the
julia child challenge which is a
competition show where chefs will
recreate julia's classic recipes it's
literally going to be like a side by
side and it's all for a chance for the
prize to go to a french cooking school
take a
cook alongside their hero lulu is really
yummy who also started as a home cook i
just love to walk around in the kitchen
and found her calling later in life
welcome to the french chef i'm junior
child they'll cook in a kitchen just
like hers it's so close to the real
thing with the same ingredients that she
used that made her voila
i mean if this isn't appointment tv i
don't know what is it starts tonight on
the food network
this was interesting the movie dune um
has 10 oscar nominations and is getting
a sequel oh wow
and timothy chalamet and zendaya will be
back for part two but the hollywood
reporter says they might be joined by
none other than
i'm not kidding one of my favorite
actresses in the world and rocked it as
scar joe's sister in uh black widow
florence pugh love her
she's in talk to play princess ear alone
and the deal is not final but this is
where it gets interesting florence is
one of the very finalists um for the
madonna movie to play madonna but they
film at the same time oh
plot twist you know agents are so hot to
trot right right they're like buy sell
buy sell you can have her you can't have
her you want her you got a pony up i
mean this is so fun
hollywood bananas god
happy st patrick's day everyone now 54
of adults are celebrating today and
rossi guess economically speaking how
much money people are spending on this
holiday i have no idea hold on to your
leprechaun hat rossi because martha
stewart magazine reports that people
will spend 5.87
billion dollars what what
so i'm like what it's a lot of you know
alcohol and shamrock shakes and bar
business and listen this is good for the
economy yeah the average person will
spend about 42 bucks on everything from
green clothes to corned beef and green
beer so hey
happy st patrick's day and happy boost
to the economy well yeah i think when
it's high spray
5.7 billion seems like a lot but when
you break it down like 42 yeah like i
bought this green shirt i didn't have a
green shirt but i knew i wanted to wear
a green shirt you know i love the color
of that green it's got a lot of blue and
it's very attractive thank you thank you
[Music]